[موسيقى]
مزرعه الاسكا داخل الاكسبو سيتي هي مزرعه
داخليه اللي هي كت كنترول و ما بنستخدم
مبيدات كمان نستخدم 95% مي اقل لما تكون ك
لزراعه التقليديه مشان هيك فينا ننتج كل
السنه بالصيف بالشتاء شو ما في عوامل
خارجيه هدف من المزرعه هي بتساعد على
تامين الامن الغذائي طبعا لانه المزرعه
موجوده جوات اكسبو سيتي
والمطاعم اللي باكسبو سيتي بتاخذ من
المزرعه فعمل النقل بتكون بعيده بس عده
امتار فبنو كثير على البصمه الكربونيه من
خلال عمليه النقل عمليه الزراعه ها لانه
داخليه ما بتعتمد على الشمس فعنا الاضاءه
اللي هي ال اي دي هذه المزرعه العموديه
بتستخدم تكنولوجيا عاليه فكل ده تدوير
المياه في بكون سنسز اللي هي حساسات بتقيس
المناخ الداخلي جوات المزرعه في عمليه
التحكم عن بعد بسبب هذا الشيء عمليه
الحصاد بس بصير تقريبا مره او مرتين
بالاسبوع بس غير هيك العمال ما بيحتاج
يفوتوا على المزل وهذا الشيء بخليها تكون
دائما
انظف لانه الاستهلاك فوري نقطفها لما تكون
نضجه ما محتاجين نقطفها قبل نضوج فمان هيك
بتكون دائما يعني بكون اقوى والغذاء فيها
بكون دائما اعلى لانه ما بتقعد وقت طويل
بين النقل
والتبريد